[Musik]
die stärksten und deswegen möchte mein
held vom österreichischen bundesheer
genau anschauen
sie haben eine aufs gas dann 63 kilo
schwer und sind straßen und gelände tot
ist
[Musik]
das quad ist auch eine visual
geländefahrzeug gut vier rädern oder
raupen man kann maximal zwei zonen
auslastungsbedingt und niederrhein
mitfahren
[Musik]
das quad ist verwendet weil ein
euro-land report erst danach wieder
andere extras wie infrarot scheinwerfers
nacht fallen ja das gefühl es ist für
sensibel und reagiert in kürzester zeit
[Musik]
der vorteil von quatsch es einfach dass
die soldaten unter schwierigen
bedingungen im hochgebirge extrem
beweglich sind und damit einfach
verletzte personen viel schneller bergen
und retten können
[Musik]